[Musique]
Je ne pouvais pas aimer quand je suis allé dans le bus
et qu'il y avait une lettre z ouais
j'essayais d'aimer l'arracher comme si je
ne pouvais pas aimer
euh je ne pouvais pas vivre avec
[Musique]
que je suis devenu anash alors je  j'ai obtenu ma
citoyenneté le
7 juillet octobre ouais c'était surprenant bien
sûr et j'avais peur euh et c'était
ouais c'était un peu intéressant de
devoir vivre la deuxième guerre comme
de l'autre côté maintenant mais un peu
ouais quand même mais ici  c'est différent comme
ici c'est différent j'ai l'impression d'être
chez moi et comme si on défendait donc c'est
comme si c'est c'est c'est c'est une autre histoire
donc je vois toujours mon avenir ici bien sûr